قاموس كيم جونج اون كوريا
الشمالية تطلق صاروخا باليستيا
هو بايدن يزعم ان ابنه توفي في
العراق. المبعوث الاممي الى
تعد تعيش في امستردام ولا يسمح
لها بمغادرة منزلها وتخضع
اللحظة واذهب الى السجن وساكون
سعيدة. بعد زلات لسان كثيرة ها
الاصول المغربية. فهل يفعلها ابن
المغرب? البسوس نانسي بيلوسي
وبوتين. الانتقام الفاشل. لم تجد
التهديدات ولم تقبل الطلبات
يجب عدم العودة لدائرة العنف
والحرب. الناتو يكشر عن انيابه
ان العراق ان يفرح ولو قليلا؟
سؤال نطرحه دائما. فهل حان وقت
فورا مع روسيا لانشاء مركز لنقل
الغاز الروسي لاوروبا. اردوجان
لاجراءات امنية مشددة بسبب
تهديدات عصابة رضوان تاغي ذي
السيطرة على بلدتين في محور
باخموت ليخرج بعدها الزلامسكي
الدفاع البريطانية انها ستزود
اوكرانيا بصواريخ اضافية مضادة
غيبوبتها. ويا لهذه الفرحة
العارمة. جاء ذلك بعد اشهر من
رد موسكو فعلا وليس قولا لكنه
توجه الى فرنسا هنا البحرية
وصلت صواريخ اوكرانيا المدن
الروسية فكيف سيرد بوتين? وبينما
فما هو الحل يا بايدن? نظرية كيم
الجديدة. ثم اهرب. جملة ليست في
مقاتلات اف خمسة وثلاثين ايه لكن
بيونج يانج تتهم كوريا الجنوبية
لقد عمل المجنون بالمثل العربي
اشتكى. العراق يعود من جديد. اما
السعودية في اعقاب قرار مجموعة
اوبك بلس هي وحدة عربية وراء
الاجابة لدى عبداللطيف رشيد
ومحمد السوداني. الاحداث
الدفاعات الجوية. الرد جاء من
لندن. وبعد المانيا اعلنت وزارة
الفرنسية ترصد غواصة روسية
وتتابعها قبالة منطقة وذلك بحسب
بايدن ولم نقرر بعد بشأن
مشاركتنا في قمة العشرين. ودعا
كانت يونهاب قد قالت ان اثنتي
عشرة طائرة حربية في كوريا
الازمة السياسية مواجهات
والاعتصامات ليأتي المهنئون وفي
العربية احمد ابو الغيط حملة
التصريحات الاعلامية السلبية ضد
تهدد ترامب اذا جئت الكابيتول
ساضربك. مضيفة لقد كنت انتظر هذه
الامن القومي معلنا ان التحدي
الكبير لبلاده يتمثل في التغلب
اولئك الذين لا يشاركوننا رؤيتنا
لعالم حر ومنفتح ومزدهر وامن.
امام الرياض. جو بايدن يؤكد ان
بلاده تعتزم التفاوض مع السعودية
تعلن ان اهداف العملية العسكرية
في اوكرانيا لم تتغير لكن يمكن
المانيا الى الالتزام باتفاقات
الناتو او اتباع مصلحتها. فما
صارخا اوكرانيا تمتلك عشرة
بالمائة فقط مما تحتاجه من
الناتو وفرنسا يتعهدون بتسليم
منظومات دفاع جوي متطورة
تركيا اكثر الطرق التي يمكن
الاعتماد عليها لنقل الغاز الى
تلاحق الولايات المتحدة. لكن
اصحاب العيون الضيقة هم الهاجس
والتطورات. افادت وسائل اعلام
هولندية بان ولية عهد هولندا لم
اليمن يحمل الحوثيين مسؤولية فشل
تمديد الهدنة في البلاد. واضاف
بدعمها باقماره فضحه مسؤول رفيع
في البنتاجون بقوله. ماسك خدمة
المزيد من القوات. فهل تعتبر هذه
اشارة لانهاء الحرب لترد
غير محدد في اتجاه البحر اي اذهب
اينما ذهبت واسقط اينما سقطت.
سيتبعه رد. ليس ردا نوويا بل هو
رد قوي من الجانب العسكري لدرجة
العراقيون لكن تلك الفرحة سبقها
تعرض المنطقة الخضراء لقصف
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
السابق جون بولتون يزيد التوتر
الجامعة العربية حيث يستنكر
الامين العام لجامعة الدول
الغربية بمركز قيادة وتحكم
مشترك. فهل هذا سبب قوي كي تندلع
عسكريون تابعون لمؤسسة بوليفار
الاستخباراتية الاوكرانية. رجحوا
وايران وقطر. اما بالنسبة
لامريكا فبعد ان طلب بايدن
رويترز يا له من رد مرعب. هنا
جاء الخبر القنبلة. خبراء
الشمالية تجاوزت الخط على الحدود
والذي يفعل تلقائيا برد من
بحسب ما نقلته وكالة يونهاب
الكورية الجنوبية. لكن قبل ذلك
على بكين وكبح جماح موسكو بايدن
لن نترك مستقبلنا عرضة لاواء
الحرب العالمية? اما ايلون ماسك
من ادعى انه سيقف مع اوكرانيا
بجدية. وبعد كل هذا التهديد
والوعيد يعود ستولتنبرج ليقول
وسنواصل دعم اوكرانيا عسكريا
واقتصاديا. معتبرا خطاب الرئيس
اوكرانية بينما اعلنت القوات
الموالية لروسيا في اقليم دومباز
مقدمتهم مجلس التعاون الخليجي
واستراليا وروسيا فماذا بعد ايها
سياسي ماكر. ها هو يجتمع بشركائه
في مؤتمر سيكا في كازاخستان
ان غواصة امريكية مسيرة هي من
فجرت جسر القرم وليست شاحنة يا
العراق عبداللطيف رشيد رئيسا
للجمهورية ليكلف بعد رشيد محمد
عن كثب التدريبات النووية
الروسية المقبلة. لن للترهيب
ورادارات لاوكرانيا. لتكشف بعدها
واشنطن انها ستسعى لبناء قدرات
صاروخي ادى الى جرح عشرة اشخاص
فهل تكون تلك الضربة الاخيرة?
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين النووي
غير مسؤول وان الحلف يأخذه
جوية شاملة ودائمة لاوكرانيا
وذلك من خلال ربط الانظمة
المملكة ام ان هناك مآرب اخرى
للعرب. كابوس واشنطن. الكوابيس
بعمل استفزازي قرب الحدود والذي
يثير توترا عسكريا بحد وصفها.
اشتعالا. ويقول ان اذا لجأ
لاستخدام الاسلحة النووية في
شياع السوداني بتشكيل مجلس
الوزراء الازمة العراقية تفوق من
اذا اردتم اقماري ادفعوا والا
فليس لي علاقة بحربكم. واشنطن
كبير من الدول. فهل يكون هذا
المنتدى هو المقابل لحلف الناتو?
اوكرانيا فقد وقع على مذكرة
انتحاره. فواشنطن ستغتاله. ويضيف
اوكرانيون ان القوات الروسية
قصفت اكثر من اربعين مدينة وبلدة
يستيقظون. بايدن يؤكد هذا الهاجس
ويضع الصين كاول في استراتيجية
بما لم يأت به احد من قبله فقال
اي هجوم نووي على اوكرانيا
بريطانيا تتحدى روسيا بانتظار رد
موسكو وليست المانيا فقط. هنا
يحاول اردوجان الوساطة في الحرب
الاوكرانية يكافئه بوتين بقوله
تفكك الاتحاد السوفيتي وازدياد
النزاعات في منطقة جاءت فكرة
الجنوب ما دفع سيئون الى ارسال
مقاتلات لاعتراضها بما في ذلك
بخطوة عسكرية جعلت امن فرنسا في
مهب الريح. فما هي هذه الخطوة?
للطائرات وصواريخ من طراز امرام
القادرة على اسقاط صواريخ كروز.
بشأن قرار اوبك بلس الاخير. لكن
ماذا عن الانتقام يا وهنا
وبمشاركة عدد من رؤساء الدول
ابرزهم قادة تركيا وقطر
الفرح اليوم لتتنفس بلاد
الرافدين الصعداء؟ وبعد ان انتخب
مجانية في اوكرانيا وبعد ان
اعتمد الكثير عليها ها هو في
تحقيقها مفاوضات في اشارة
لامكانية انهاء الحرب. ويقول
اوكرانيا بقصف مدينة بلجرود
الروسية وتحقيق اضرار عديدة؟ نعم
تجاه الحرب الاوكرانية ام ان
هناك رابطا خفيا بين ايلون ماسك
وارتفعت الاهات. لتجد نفسها
معلنة عن اول التنازلات واشنطن
لا يملك وقتا ليضيع هذه الفرصة.
على ارض المعركة قال مسؤولون
النهاية يرسل الفاتورة للوزارة
ويريد الثمن. فهل انتهى كرم الون
الاكبر لواشنطن والذي يقلق
منامهم ويسلب عليهم راحتهم عندما
الذي يخطط له بوتين يا ترى? اما
الرئاسة الروسية وفي تصريح مفاجئ
اوروبا. ليطلق اردوجان امره
لوزير الطاقة التركية ببدء العمل
للقوات الروسية ستنتهي خلال
اسبوعين ولا حاجة الى تعبئة
مقابلة بوتين ها هو يرفض الطلب
وقال لا ارى اهمية للحوار مع
نعم وبدون مبالغة فالمنتدى توجد
فيه دول كروسيا والصين وتركيا
الاجواء المشتعلة الى الدهائس
بوتين ليس مصارعا فقط انما هو
تأسيس المنتدى للعمل على انشاء
ترابط اقتصادي وسياسي بين عدد
موسكو تعمل على اعادة النظر في
المنظومة المالية العالمية فبعد
للجنون. ايعقل هذا؟ الحرب تستعر.
فمن يوقد الشرارة الاولى؟ ومن
واذربيجان وايران والعراق
وباكستان وفلسطين. بوتين قال ان
المتحدة في هذا الموقف الصعب.
زعيم كوريا الشمالية ضربني وبكى
اذا فعلها فهو يقودنا الى هرم
جدون معركة نهاية العالم. ليأتي
تتنازل للرياض والجامعة العربية
ترد وفخ صيني يضع الولايات
اشدها والتوترات تزداد. وما من
انفراجة تلوح في الافق فليس هناك
الا التهديد. الامين العام
للنايتو بيرج يقول الحيث سيراقب
السبب بوتين يرفض طلب مقابلة
بايدن زيلنسكي لا يتوقف عن الطلب
وبوتين يرد على طريقته الخاصة
بينما يبحث عن حل وسط فهل ينجح?
الفرح وهفوات بايدن لا تنتهي.
موسكو ترعب باريس. الخطابات على
ان الجيش الروسي سيهلك. ما كل
هذا الغضب ايها الاوروبيون.
لن نخضع للترهيب وجيش بوتين
سيباه. الناتو يهدد ليرد بوتين
الحلف ليس طرفا في النزاع بين
روسيا واوكرانيا الى غرابة
تصريحاتك يا هذا. هنا مسؤول
السياسة الخارجية في الاتحاد جاء
بوتين لا نريد تدمير اوكرانيا
والتعبئة الجزئية العسكرية
وسبقني واشتكى في العراق يظهر
بصيص امل في نهاية فهل حان وقت
واوروبا لا تتوقف العطاء لكن ليس
بالمال هذه المرة والوائل ماسك
الامريكان يخططون لاغتيال بوتين.
لكن ماذا عن هرمج الدون? ولهذا